- But speaking of balance
one thing I really did love
when I was reading your book,
and I could have used before now,
being in the midst of a divorce
is you really make a thing
about Sunday night
dinners with your family.
Y'all all get together and as a family.
And it's so important, and
I actually remember my ex
and I, we tried so hard to do that.
But you slip up, you know, you start.
It's like, okay, well we skipped this one
because we had this important obligation,
or we skip this one.
And then sooner or later you miss them.
You feel like that is kind of
a really important key thing-
- [Jill] Absolutely.
- That you and President Biden do
to keep your family kind of sacred?
- Absolutely, and so we try to keep
the Sunday nights dinners.
I mean, it's been a little busy
lately, but we still do it.
And the kids look forward to it.
And I think traditions really ground kids.
And, you know, it was funny recently
my granddaughters has called
me and they said, Nana.
You know, I'd love to have a
beautiful table with candles
and flowers or whatever
I can find to put on it.
They said, Nana, we're
making our own dinner
and we're doing it Nana style.
You know, we have our candles.
And so some of it has permeated.
I hope that they continue
on the traditions, too.
- Absolutely, I think that
the biggest thing from that
is simply just saying you
matter to take this time.
- [Jill] Sure.
- I agree.
How have traditions in general
really helped your family?
Like, 'cause now you have a daily,
isn't like a daily, you and
President Biden have dinner?
It's like date night now?
(laughing)
I love it, is it got like date night?
Like y'all have dinner every night?
- Yeah, we do.
I mean, he's so busy, I'm so busy.
But we do keep dinner.
And we have dinner together, no phones.
You know, the phones have to be off.
And now we're having dinner
in this beautiful home,
and there's a fireplace in the dining room
and they light the fire and we just sit
and talk for a while.
And then he has to go
back to work, you know
into the night, and I'm grading papers.
- That sounded very The American President
with Michael Douglas and Annette Bening.
(laughing)
And I was very into it.
How else do you unwind,
especially in such a tense job
and environment, how do you unwind?
- You know, I'm a big, I
mean, I love to exercise.
- Oh I wish I did.
- And I run, I bike, it clears my head.
So that's really important to me.
And I think all women
should have something.
It doesn't have to be exercise,
although hopefully it would be.
- I wish it would be, Dr. Biden.
- Just to take a moment
for yourself, you know.
So I get up early and that's
my time that I have for myself.
- I think all women, especially parents,
it has to be early because
if you don't do it,
if it's not the first thing you do-.
- You lose the day.
- [Kelly] It never happens, yeah, I agree.